there grounding drones in Florida and
cracking down on seniors who play ultra
small stakes card games in Indiana this
time we stay in the Hoosier State we're
busy bodies are also very happy to hound
a young let them help it is now against
the law for any driver under 21 to use
their cell phone on the road many young
drivers are surprised to learn about the
van which means no hands-free devices no
pandora and no GPS the only thing that's
legal is calling 911 11 that if you're
using an electronic device while you're
driving your four times more likely to
have an accident and I'm sure that
studies show that teens follow laws or
maybe they'll replace hands-free
chatting with some sneaky cat scene
which is harder for cops the spot and
poses more dangers for travelers well
you can bet who's your lawmakers
carefully mold all possible unintended
consequences after carefully reading the
bill wait hold on I learned it on the
news but I didn't remember that
happening representative Dan Leonard
says about the band he says he tries to
read all the bills but things can always
slip by well at least he tries and if
something does slip by he can always
learn it on the news it turns out at
least three other representatives who
voted for house bill 1394 didn't realize
it included a squeaking cellphone ban
way to go democracy following in a the
month on Twitter submit your nanny
nominees and check back next month for
the very last episode of many of the
month
you